today Facebook paused eight new people
per second or twenty eight thousand
eight hundred people every single hour
in 2015
Facebook was responsible for 22% of
worldwide mobile internet advertising
furthermore Facebook stores about 300
petabytes or 300 thousand terabytes of
the user data on its servers and its
creator Mark Zuckerberg is one of the
youngest billionaires live with a net
worth of 66 billion dollars as it is
evident Facebook has grown to become one
of the biggest companies in the world in
the past decade but where did it all
begin but before we get into that make
sure to hit the subscribe button if you
guys would like to see more origin
stories just like this one and comment
what company you would like me to cover
next so starting off Facebook was
launched way back on February 5th 2004
by Mark Zuckerberg and his college
roommate Eduardo Saverin at Harvard
University originally Facebook was only
available to Harvard students but soon
enough expanded into other colleges in
Boston area and eventually to other Ivy
League colleges and finally most
universities and corporations in the
United States and Canada by 2006
everyone who had a valid email address
and were at least 13 put on a Facebook
account Facebook wasn't Mark Zuckerberg
first entry in this room though Mark had
been using computers and writing
software since middle school and even
took private software development
lessons when he was in high school he
developed a software program which he
named suck net that helped his dad won
his dental business more efficiently
mark was also very intelligent which can
be seen in the fact that he was accepted
into Harvard even at Harvard mark was
known as a program prodigy by his peers
while at Harvard mark wrote a program
called coursematch which enabled his
users to choose classes based on the
disease
of their peers and it assisted in
creating study groups soon after he
developed a program called facematch
that allowed its users to choose best
looking person by looking at pictures
side by side the site was so popular
that harbor shut it down after just a
couple days because I'd have overwhelmed
one of harvard's because they had
overwhelmed one of harvard's network
switches furthermore the program was
notorious for using people's pictures
without their permission
which was code completely improper later
on Park started up Facebook but three
seniors cameron winklevoss tyler
winklevoss and divya narendra accused
him and ended up receiving 1.2 million
shares of Facebook because mark can used
their combined ideas in order to make
Facebook today all of them are doing
well too so I think it worked out for
them but I was stuck knowing that you
could have been something exponentially
better anyways going back to Facebook
mark was really able to grow Facebook
into something much bigger mark meant
peter thiel was a major investor in the
company and got their first office in
2004 Park had even turned down good
offers from major companies to buy
Facebook by the end of 2007 Facebook had
100 thousand business pages which
enabled companies to attract potential
customers by informing vast quantities
of people about their businesses in 2008
Facebook announced their plans to
establish Facebook international
headquarters in Dublin Ireland in 2010
Facebook began to hire beta testers
after they passed a question and answer
based selection process by February of
2011 Facebook can become the largest
photo host with estimated pictures above
100 billion however now everything was a
breeze in March of 2012 yahoo filed a
lawsuit against facebook claiming that
10 of its patents or big infringed upon
by facebook however fortunately for both
companies they were able to work it out
without any cash finally in
18 2012 Facebook went public
what did speak market capitalization of
over 104 billion dollars the company
have won a largest IPOs or initial
public offerings in history however
there seemed to be some issue with the
stock price and by June 6th investors
had collectively lost 40 billion dollars
furthermore over 40 lawsuits were filed
for the misleading IPO despite this
Facebook continued to prosper and in
2013 they entered the fortune 500 list
462 meanwhile Facebook was investing in
too many companies which would also
become very popular like Instagram Glenn
C lightbox and spa and many more all in
just 2012 some of the most popular
companies they invested in the following
years included whatsapp oculus VR and
tbh just a few months ago for Facebook
most of these investments have more than
paid for themselves and have boosted
Facebook's substantially even now it's
not smooth sailing for Facebook though
and Facebook still faces a plethora of
lawsuits for example the connect user in
Pakistan the Palestinian and Hawaiian
lawsuits investigations and issues are
just a few Facebook had to get through
in the past years recently Facebook has
been heavily criticized for not
respecting its user privacy and mark had
to go through a lengthy Congress
interrogation just very recently as that
issue has start to have subside Facebook
was hit with another massive lawsuit
just a couple days ago apparently it is
legal for Facebook to allow its users to
tag firms in photos with the help of
facial recognization reservoir recently
marks networks have dropped by a
staggering 5.1 billion dollars in just a
couple hours as it is clear
Facebook is a bit of a sticky situation
right now on top of this only 56% of
Americans trust Facebook which is the
least out of any major tech companies as
a result Facebook definitely has its
flaws and still has a lot of
to improve however Facebook is the most
popular social media website available
right now and we'll keep that title for
the foreseeable future meanwhile Mark
Zuckerberg likes to live simple with his
G's a t-shirt and simple Volkswagen car
he has even pledged to donate ninety
nine percent of his facebook shares to
charity as time goes on
overall Facebook has some shady
beginnings and is still facing various
issues today but it is undeniable that
mark has created a new type of future in
terms of social networking that will
last for a very long time so what do you
guys think is next for Facebook do you
think Facebook is going to die
eventually and will be replaced by other
social media apps or do you think
Facebook is going to stay for a long
time whether we like it or not due to
the vast user base it has established
make sure to post down and comment below
what you guys think and while you are at
it don't forget to hit the like button
and if you guys enjoyed this video and
would like to see more videos just like
this way
consider subscribing also make sure to
post what company you would like to me
to cover next but until next time bye
[Music]